طريقه السفر في تغيير مستمر وسريع فوسائل
النقل اصبحت اكثر متعه وتقدما يوما اثر
يوم فماذا لو كنت قادرا على السفر حول
العالم او حتى الكون ولكن دون ان تتحرك
قيد انمله من بيتك كانت الرحله الى مكان
بعيد تستغرق اسابيع بل شهورا للتخطيط
والاعداد والتعامل مع وكلاء السفر واعداد
الكتب والخرائط وكل شيء بالاضافه الى
اضراب الرحلات الجويه الطويله وبفضل
المطورين المبدعين الان يمكنك الذهاب الى
اي مكان تتمناه حول العالم ولكن دون ان
تغير مكانك قد لا يكون هذا سفرا بالمعنى
الحرفي ولكن شركات مثل اوكولوس ريفت و
بروجكت مورفيوس منحت الناس النقل
الافتراضي وتوفر شركه الضياف ماريوت
اجازات افتراضيه للمتزوجين حديثا بواسطه
اجهزه تمنح رؤيه ثلاثيه الابعاد فتشعر
وكانك في المكان الذي تختاره ولكن ليس من
الضروري شراء جهاز مكلف لرؤيه العالم
فبامكان الشخص استخدام جوجل مابس قد
يستغرق السفر من مدينه نيويورك الى
الحديقه الوطنيه 37 ساعه من قياده
السيارات ولكن يمكنك فعل هذا وبصوره واضحه
للغايه في ثوان معدودا فقط عبر جوجل مابس
بل انه بامكانك ايضا قيام بزياره بحريه
تحت الماء انطلاقا من
المكسيك